high fashion food a silent auction all
for a good cause the clark county
medical society alliance is hosting its
21st annual fashion show coming up march
10th for the event it sells out every
year but there are some tickets left you
do have to hurry though because those
online ticket sales end tonight at
midnight and this is an event you don't
want to miss
it will be a full on
runway
fashion show with fashions provided by
anne fontaine
which is a wonderful parisian
fashion house that's located in the
forum shops
the clark county medical society
alliance formed more than 70 years ago
to promote health education and
philanthropy this year's event benefits
project 150 which provides basic
necessities to high school students
these are kids who are uh coach surfing
they're living on the street they really
don't have a place to call home and the
last thing they really need to be doing
is figuring out where they're going to
get food from
the event is at the four seasons again
i'm so honored to be the mc i hope you
can come tickets are 275 a person but if
you can't make it don't worry they still
need your help no amount is too small
ccmsa is taking donations through the
event which is march 10th